parce qu'on voulait appeler michel cymes
oui je passe il a gardé son numéro mais
alors vous vous entendez bien avec lui
ouais ça va j'ai croisé à europe 1 il ya
deux ans
une hausse de 0 7 k way ça
bayrou s'est platement vie devant ton
qu'est ce que tu veux dire merci comme
ceux ci
allaient au michel
oui bonjour michel c'est guillaume
genton
on s'était croisé à votre année vous
allez bien
oui
en fait je suis une émission avec
fabrice di vizio
et puis par bruce et moi benjamin
castaldi
oui oui
ap ap rès capte mal en fait on
[Musique]
tu m'as vraiment oui map non mais pas
renversant et on voulait réagir à vos
propos sur un plateau
vide jour là
[Rires]
m non mais là il vous a répondu il vous
a répondu là il est soit pas tout dit
sur le plateau jours voilà
non non non je passe mon temps à
l'éléphant la même chose
juste un mot pendant qu effectivement
certains parlaient d'une petite grippe
moi je me battais pour qu'ils aient des
masques mais sinon c'est pas grave
ah oui ça fait bien au départ ils
m'écoutent et
non si vous n'écoutez pas je vous écoute
pas déplu c'est la réciprocité
décidément décidément c'est une
obsession
non chez les personnes vaccinées ça
donne ça redevienne 9,7 sur décidément
bien attraper les autres
maintenant attendez maintenant si vous
voulez bien effectivement et ce midi à
paris
mais vous voulez me frapper le minimum
ce que vous voulez de frapper le
vignoble c'est qu'on discute j'aimerais
bien ça et l'expression docteur cymes
nous regardent en tout cas encore c'est
une expression décidément que
d'expression
et vous vous êtes quoi auteurs s'y
mettre à jour la liste annoncée pas vrai
médecin annonce voulait plus non plus
présentateur des changes est là pour
arranger les choses
je sais pas je me fais agresser en 10
secondes moi je veux bien dialoguer mais
si jamais le club finesse non pardon
monsieur cymes vous êtes qu est ce qui
fait quand même pas vous gratifier titre
de l'auteur qui réservait aux médecins
inscrits à l'ordre mais je veux dire si
vous voulez dialoguer au dialogue
maintenant si vous voulez une trappe et
il faudra venir sur le plateau pour le
faire ah oui
on y parle des mois moi je ne cherche à
impressionner personnes effectivement
absolument personne parce que la
différence avec vous c'est qu'en fait
j'ai pas besoin d'impressionner qui que
ce soit j'ai un vrai boulot un vrai
métier voilà et que j'exerce
effectivement quotidiennement confiance
entre nous maintenant vous avez une
curieuse conception du dialogue mais
c'est pas grave alors est ce que peut
dire un mot sur un benjamin castaldi
michel vous m'entendez ya benjamin
castaldi qu'elle a aussi confié avoir de
frapper aussi c'est juste pour mon
action
[Applaudissements]
alors que tous étaient gentils
[Musique]
je me rappelle que quatre cas dire à
barack obama il ya quelque chose
du personnage quand même éditeur un
essai noah à part ça
appartement on est là pour se
réconcilier
non non non c'est ça s'appelle l'impro
mais ça a beau ne va pas connaître parce
que vous avez un prompteur que vous avez
munitions non
excusez-moi trucs gentils à lui disant
écoute et non en tout cas moi michel g
rien contre vous j'ai omis le chrono
vous aviez fait à tâtons midi on avait
rappelé à mais apparemment on était très
fier c'était rien personnel honnêtement
on sait juste interrogé sur les
audiences
assez assez mauvaise que vous faites
depuis quelques temps à la télévision
que tout soit l'émission culte seul
format et quelques shows à l'horaire et
que c'est toujours voilà n'est pas bon
ce qui est ce que est ce qui là est ce
qu'il ya une protection ou est ce qu'il
n'est pas
vous êtes heure belge exactement 10 à la
normale oui c'était ça la raison les
mecs qui fasse audience novès et ou bien
pas tout le temps
est ce que vous pensez qu'il a eue somme
après top gear mais ça mais c'est parce
que ça m'énerve et déjà prête au pire ça
c'est clair j'ai déjà dit et puis
après son bond à la différence en promo
d'un à catalyser moi c'est que
apparemment on dit
ldl vous avez 12 ans d'âge c'est aussi
ce type mais c'est ouf mais attendez
vous non mais c'est simon tahar ben
m'hidi synaeghel alors certes pas mais
on essaie de m
[Applaudissements]
il est extraordinaire ce garçon fait
péter la gueule je veux dire table d'un
mot tata meilleur chrono coin caisse de
l'aquila alors il avait senti plein ce
qui pleuvent 107 nations
merci messieurs non vous en derniers
mois
n'ont pas à l'égard des médecins à votre
égard il est une chose nous on ne vit
pas dans le monde tous les médecins vous
mettez pas dans le lot de tous les
médecins c'est contre vous pas contre
les médecins celle ci contre vous et
vous il ya un truc que je sais c'est que
m ça voulait plus et au moins c'est la
bonne nouvelle du soir
il l'a dit c'est ce que vous voulez pas
nous réconcilier avec moi
[Musique]
vous avez dit quoi vous attendiez
sûr d'une chose c'est que si je
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout
justement
c'est
juste un truc je voulais juste dire que
ce truc la différence entre vous et moi
chers amis c'est moi j'ai jamais menacé
personne et en l'occurrence
effectivement c'est bien beau de menacer
mais pour l'instant sur le plateau vous
n'êtes pas venu parce que même être face
à moi vous n'avez pas le courage
débattre avec moi vous n'avez pas le
courage alors de là à vouloir me frapper
mort de rire
castanet boudé non moi je vais vous
démontez trucs gentils un derby c'est
toujours moi je n'ai rien sur de bonnes
bases et n'est rien d'autre qu'un
anticorps partir de narnia 3 2 millions
contre michel mais visiblement il a été
touché parce qu'on a des jeux je tiens à
m'en excuser
réconcilier michel par les
basses et vous que le temps du messie
mais avec fabrice dhainaut pas non plus
je suis tranquille chez moi
sympa ça va dresser
futile voilà c'est futile un dernier mot
au revoir
[Rires]
bon
c'est pas très content d'une
compensation ou non apparemment ça peut
peut-être s'arranger donc c'est bien en
tout cas le dialogue n'est pas rompu il
exactement franchement ça par michel
cymes près n'importe quoi parce que
je si metz
merci d'avoir répondu en tout cas oui
merci on vous retrouve demain sur vous
êtes toujours sur une radio
c'est berriane jamais le limitateur
ni ball
ces gens
[Applaudissements]
c'est lent
c'est bon par contre vous et vous seriez
vous avez dit vous avez des mines dans
le pas du tout les
[Applaudissements]
tats unis qui touche dans le séparait
des pois chiches des pois chiches va
maintenant se réconcilient je vais pas
l'attaquer comme sur route 2000
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave c'est
parce qu'il est comme ça on aime bien